now to our coverage of the corona virus  pandemic let's take a look at the latest  numbers here and we're gonna start with  numbers from around the country there  are now more than 2 million reported  positive cases due to recent spikes in a  handful of cities more testing is taking  place as well more than a hundred 12,000  people nationwide have died from the  disease those are the numbers in Nevada  more than 100 new cases and four more  deaths reported today in Nevada there  are now more than 9700 cases and 442  deaths most of the cases and deaths come  from here in Clark County nearly 7600  people have caught the corona virus here  in Southern Nevada 363 people have died  and we update these numbers every day at  8 News now.com there's a lot more  information for you there as well